bienvenue à Clearwater Marine Aquarium
comment est-ce que tout le monde aujourd'hui
aime que les hivers soient très ludiques aujourd'hui
monsieur est une telle inspiration pour moi
n'est-elle pas juste incroyable votre femelle
gros nez hiver elle ne va pas bien
argile personne n'est autorisé à revenir ici les hivers
ne se sentent pas très bien
voir jamais venir  pas grand-chose c'est dur même les
gens sont dehors pour manger vous avez une sorte de
bacon comment ça se passe en hiver doit
être jumelé avec une autre femelle et bientôt
je vous donne 30 jours pour corriger le
problème
hé les gars Marine Fisheries vient de ramasser
un échouage  argile c'est une femme d'
accord tout le monde quand ce camion
arrivera vous entendrez une voix et ce sera la
mienne Sawyer je te veux juste à côté de moi
c'est ours
elle est si petite nous devons aller vite sous l'eau
je vais la prendre moi-même
maintenant tout ce que nous pouvons faire c'est  j'espère que c'est son
nom bonjour
pouvons-nous parler de l'associer à l'
hiver vous ne pouvez pas simplement jeter deux dauphins
et les eaux ensemble ils ne s'aiment pas
nous perdrons l'hiver que sommes-nous
censés faire  c'est un grand sol fertile, il
faut le secouer de temps en temps, je sais que l'
hiver, nous ne lui donnons pas cette chance,
que faisons-nous, je ne veux pas revenir
en arrière en sachant que nous n'avons même pas essayé, désolé,
c'est vrai mon  sentiments exactement
Oh où est ta chaussure
nous ne savons pas avec certitude des
amitiés sur le terrain des dauphins on dirait qu'ils le font ce n'est
pas une mauvaise chose